hello everyone this week we are going to
be talking about the symbolism of hair
how it relates to death how it relates
to power how relates to covering it's
going to be continuing the discussion
that I've been having after the video I
made on the Lord of the Rings and also
this last video I made on technology and
so I think I think there'll be a lot to
talk about hopefully we'll be able to
bring together the biblical elements but
it will also help you to understand how
hair functions in our life but also in
all kinds of stories
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all I want to welcome you to
the new set of the symbolic world for
the since December I've been working on
trying to change this little office
space that I have into something a
little bit more akin to a studio so now
I have lighting I have a different
camera and I also put up some art in the
background some lighting so hopefully
you'll have something to look at except
my face when you're watching my videos I
will probably in the next QA I will
explain some of the the different why I
put up all these different pieces of art
and maybe I'll mention them in in other
videos as well but this video on the
symbolism of hair was suggested by Jakob
Russell Jakob Russell I've mentioned
before he runs the symbolic world
Facebook group I'll put a descript to
that in the description and Jakob that
if you if you're looking to continue the
discussion on everything we're doing
here really that has is turning out to
be the best place there's an ongoing
discussion people posting people
interacting with each other people also
helping each other out on their own
journey to kind of on integrate the
symbolism into their lives I tend to pop
in there as well I leave comments
reactions and sometimes I'll even post
something there and and once in a while
you might get some some previews that
only supporters usually have access to
so if you want to continue the
discussion I would suggest that you and
you go there and so the discussion in
this video is going to be about hair it
is a very difficult discussion and
that's why I in a certain manner took so
long before Jacob asked me to make this
video to get to it and the reason why I
took so long as I needed to make a few
videos hopefully to prepare people in
their thinking for this video that's why
I made the video for the One Ring in
Lord of the Rings and I also put up that
little this last video on technology
because hair is a it has to do with a
very large paradox in Scripture which
I've talked about quite a bit which is
the relationship between death and glory
how in the story of Scripture glory
turns into
but then also death is turned into glory
and we see that of course when I say
that there's an intuition we have this
intuition that there it's right you know
think about how we celebrate war heroes
um but also think of the story of Christ
himself who on the cross brought those
elements together where he was both in
his lowest point in terms of of dying
but also as Christians we believe that
he was also attaining the highest point
and entering into the Holy of Holies of
the temple at the same time and so those
two things come together seems like a
paradox but hopefully I'll be able to at
least point you to some to some elements
which can help you understand how this
is possible and it's important to
understand that because of what's
happening right now and because of all
the things that happen in society it
seems like we need more people who are
able to flip the script we're able to
change death back into glory and so
hopefully this will be a little bit of a
help and so when we look at hair we have
to understand we have to look at hair
just look at what it is that's always a
key to understanding what symbolism is
what is hair how does it function not in
terms of scientific composition but
really in terms of how we experience
hair and and when we we kind of
understand that we'll be able to to
understand how it works what's the
function of hair well we know that the
hair is there to protect you right you
have hair all over your body
you have hair on your head to protect
you from the Sun to protect you from the
cold you have eyebrows to protect you
know your eyes from from sweat and so
hair is related to this notion of the
garments of skins so I've mentioned this
100 times before but for those you
haven't heard it when Adam and Eve fell
in the Garden of Eden
God gave them these garments of skin and
the garments of skin are have to be
understood as as this kind of layer of
death that is put around Adam and Eve in
order to protect them from the world of
death and so it's like a layer of death
to protect you from death and you can
understand that in terms of hair
is a perfect example because hair is
dead and this is explicitly mentioned in
the Church Fathers especially st.
Gregory of Nyssa who talks about how
hair is a symbol of death because it
doesn't have any feeling and because you
know and we can keep going because it is
the thing which grows out of you but
then is also not totally you and so as
we understand this notion of something
which grows out of you but it's not
completely you it's like a dead version
of you we can understand it we can
extend it to pretty much everything
which is external to you so we have to
link this symbolism of hair to the
symbolism of power of power to act in
the world or strength strength to be
able to act in a world because all that
you do that you build a house let's say
you write something let's say all your
actions are coming from you but they are
also these remnants of you there are
also these dead these dead aspects of
you but they are not only that but they
are also your glory because they are
that which comes out of you and also is
that's what people see of you and so
they also act as this this glory okay
and so as we move on as I show you and I
give you examples of this hopefully
you'll be able to to understand a little
more as I show you the biblical examples
and so there are many places in in
Scripture which will make this
interesting connection between hair
between death and glory so for example
there is a verse in Proverbs which talks
about how a gray head is a crown of
glory it is found in the way of
righteousness and so here we have this
beautiful relationship between the idea
of aging and approaching death the idea
of this hair becoming white and so
showing this this this coming closer to
death but also becoming a a glory and so
I mean it's very intuitive if you
encounter
this person with white hair you have
light coming out of their hair coming
out of their head so you have these
these strands of light which come out of
your head and so it becomes this crown
of glory but it is also a sign of death
there's a place in scripture where talks
about how the young should rise up and
stand you know an honor the aged and the
gray headed the people who have white
hair and then you should also Revere God
and so this relationship between the
glory of the person but then also you
know moving up towards the glory of God
basically and so once you understand
that this idea of white hair as being
this connection between death and glory
and also just the idea of light coming
out of someone's head you can also
understand how why for example in the
Book of Daniel the son of man and then
in the Book of Revelations the returning
Christ is represented as having a white
hair hair as white as wool because there
it is again that relationship between
between death and glory but you can also
understand there's another place for
example in in in Corinthians where it
talks about how women should have long
hair because it is their glory and so
you can all you can see how this hair is
a covering and is a glory now this is
something that a lot of people struggle
to kind of understand because they tend
to think of glory as just light but in
Scripture it really isn't just light
there is a there it's light but it's
also a kind of dark covering at the same
time the perfect example is of course in
the Transfiguration where Christ is
transfigured and then the disciples are
are see this blinding light and then it
talks about how this light cloud
overshadowed them so there's this coming
together of light and darkness of
showing and hiding and that is really
the paradox of every
thing which is exterior exterior to
yourself you know I talked about this
with the ring anything that shows you
also hides you - it can also come to
hide you at a certain extent
everything you do externally can show
who you are but it can also be a way of
hiding you and once you understand that
you can understand so many things that
Christ talks about in the New Testament
that's why Christ is so obsessed with
hypocrisy that's why almost everything
Christ says is about dealing with
hypocrisy because Christ wants doesn't
want there to be this your outer actions
to be a form of death but wants or outer
actions to be connected to you and be a
form of glory okay and so that's why
Christ is always talking about one of
the reasons why Christ is constantly
talking about hypocrisy as being one of
the main problems and so this idea that
hair that let's say white hair we talked
about this white hair which is glory
well there are also places in scripture
where it is more strictly related to
death for example in Leviticus it talks
about a form of leprosy in which the the
one of the signs of the leprosy is that
the hair is Indian where the in the
infection the hair in the the place
where there's leprosy has turned white
and so that becomes one of the markers
to know that this person is impure and
has to be put aside now this is really
now we're diving into we're diving into
the deep stuff of symbolism which is
like I said symbolism is structural and
so the glory on your head the white hair
will set you aside will will mark you
will be a crown an ornament which will
mark you as being different from others
in a good way so it shows you our glory
and then the white hair in the infection
will also set you aside will become like
an ornament something which makes you
special but in a bad way
it's
set you aside makes you impure and so
there are these two extremes you can
imagine one which is being set aside in
the right way that is set aside for
holiness and another which is being set
aside you know cast off because it is
impure because it is it doesn't it
doesn't fit now there's there's a
there's a very like I said because
symbolism is structural you can use
sometimes the same symbolism to talk
about one side and to talk about the
other and we saw that right now in this
idea of white hair okay now because like
I talked about this notion of the
garments of skin as something to protect
us from the world hair is something to
protect us from the world also hair as
being something which comes out of you
but it's not totally you then it becomes
related to power in general to strength
and so of course when I say that
everybody will think of the story of
Samson which it makes it makes absolute
sense that it it can be that it would
come to that because the story of Samson
is exactly about that this idea of this
long hair which becomes the key to his
strength and you know because it is this
strength really really strength in in a
very physical way that is the capacity
to act upon the world capacity to beat
up someone capacity to to build a house
capacity to do to do to act or to
protect yourself from the outer world in
that sense like real power physical
power and and so the hair becomes an
image of that and it also becomes a akin
to your actions right to your outer
actions so for example a good example of
this notion of how it can be related to
your outer actions and kind of how you
act in the world a good example is the
story of Absalom zest or the son of
David in the story of apps in the story
of apps on it talks about how he had
this beautiful long hair right and so he
he had this hair that was so long and so
beautiful that every year he would have
to cut it because he became too heavy
and so he had to cut his beautiful hair
because it became too heavy then
back again and so this is really this
image of epsilon as being as being you
know the up and comer this young buck
who's wanting to replace wants to
replace his father through his own kind
of power his own his own strength but
then epsilon gets caught up in his outer
power and his hair gets caught in a tree
and as his hair is caught in a tree then
the David soldiers are able to kill him
and so there you can see how you know
that this strength this outer strength
is is a it's a danger because if you
rely on it then you can also become it
can catch you up you know you know we've
talked about that before in terms of
Technology how every time you give into
outer strength or when to rely on your
outer strength
you also make yourself weaker because
you become dependent on your capacity to
act in the world and those things will
you know those things will go away you
know though our strength our power to
act in the world will disappear and so
that's why for example you'll see in the
New Testament there's a way to kind of
play with those those relationships
where for example you know an
interesting to two interesting ideas in
the New Testament two images of hair
come up which are very fascinating to
help you understand how you can
emphasize different different aspects
for example in in the Epistle to Timothy
st. Paul talks about how he says that
that women should not adorn that should
be modest and should not adorn
themselves extremely with braided hair
and gold and costly garments and so he's
talking about this hair as an adornment
and he doesn't want women to adorn
themselves too strongly but to adorn
themselves with good works and that's a
that's what I'm talking about and so
he's saying this here are these external
signs of you and and this ornamentation
and the real glory is is is it the good
works that you do those are the good
works but you can also then oppose the
inside and the outside and st. Peter
does that himself and he says
your doorman should not be merely
external braiding the hair wearing gold
jewelry putting on dresses rather it
should be that of your inner self it
with this unfading beauty you know which
is great in God's sight and so he's
saying so you could say you're you
you're outside work should be should be
good your glory should be good but
instead of be just being this kind of
pretty adornment your work should should
be your right the adornment but then you
can also oppose them and say you know
you shouldn't focus on the outside you
should focus on the inside okay so for
example also I think in the Old
Testament there's a place where it talks
about how the the glory of young men is
their strength and the honor of old men
is their gray hair so you can see again
this relationship between now
emphasizing on one side strength and
then on the other side hair but in other
places those two the hair for the young
man and its strengths are also connected
together and so it kind of shows you how
symbolism although it isn't it's never
systematic symbolism is never a
systematic thing it is it is nonetheless
coherent in how it kind of lays itself
out and and so that's how you can also
understand this idea of the Nazarites
and so Samson was a Nazarite he's a very
strange Nazarite because he actually
doesn't follow the nazzer the rules of
the Nazarite but the Nazarites were
people who dedicated themselves to God
and dedicating themselves to God they
would let their hair grow long for a
certain amount of time the time that
they were dedicated and then when their
dedication was finished then they would
cut their hair and they would offer it
to God as an offering as a burnt
offering they actually put it on the the
the on the the offering of the altar of
offerings and would offer it up to God
and so you can see once again how this
this this growing of the hair is related
to a a following of vow to to do all
these different things so
that so that then when you're done you
cut your hair you take all those works
that you've done and you bundle them up
in your hair and then you offer them up
to God as a sacrifice and what's
interesting is that the opposite can
also be true for example in the New
Testament he talked about st. Paul
cutting his hair in order to follow a
vow can you see that of course in the
act of tonsuring that that is still that
was there in the Roman army but that is
also still there in in in the church
where you you you cut your hair in order
to to to accomplish a vow and you can
see that as starting over right cutting
your hair is like is a form of of death
as well in the sense of you remove all
this external stuff that you have it's a
it's an ascetic act you you have all
these externals and you say no I'm going
to remove them and I'm gonna focus on
this one thing and so shaving your head
cutting your hair can be a form of focus
where you're removing all these
externals all these ornaments all these
things and you are focusing on the vow
that you gave so that brings us maybe to
the last example of kind of
understanding the the relationship
between hair and works or hair and
externals is really this idea that we
see in scripture how all your hairs are
counted or this notion that no hair on
this person will be harmed for example
you see that when the three dudes are
put into the into the oven in the Book
of Daniel where it says not one hair on
their body will be damaged and so every
place where it talks about how all your
hair will be counted and and also this
notion that that no hair will fall off
or no hair will be removed it has to do
with this idea of in a certain manner of
the totality of the Incarnation or the
totality of of creation where all things
will be measured all things will be
accounted for it's related also to when
Christ talks about how you know not one
letter of the law will will fall before
the end right this idea that even the
externals this external law will all of
it
is part of this story this whole thing
and and the same with works it's like
you
what's important is let's say like st.
Peter talks about how you need to focus
on the inside and then the outside your
hair your actions your everything you do
use that external power in order to
manifest in order to to to manifest that
inner thing and then those works those
externals will become your glory right
you run the race you you attain the the
goal and then you receive a crown so
there's a relationship between this this
this glory and the actions that you you
you you put out in the world and also
let's say that you could call the
specificity of yourself that is that
which makes you you and part of it is
everything about you you're as much as
your internal as your externals all of
that is part of the the totality of what
you are and that the glory of that these
dead works these dead things that you do
you know these this art that we make
these buildings that we build the
technology that we create all of it can
be flipped can be filled with light and
become a form of glory out of there
there let's say dead selves and so
that's that's I think the symbolism of
hair I know that this might have been a
little bit convoluted because it's a
very difficult subject to talk about but
I hope that I've given enough for
everybody to at least meditate on the on
the question of hair and I think the
next video I will do will be on Rapunzel
and the story of Rapunzel as an example
of a proper use of hair its relationship
to death its relationship to to to glory
to beauty to all of that and how it all
comes together so I hope you enjoyed
this
as usual thank you for your support
shared you know all that stuff comment
you know I I don't answer a lot of the
comments but I do read them don't worry
I read pretty much all the comments and
I tried to answer once in a while so so
so stay engaged and I'll see you soon